how're the long flight to the other side
of the world in a normal plane is tough
enough so imagine making the journey in
a flimsy microlight it's taken Dave
Sykes for months to travel almost 12,000
miles to Sydney from his home in
Yorkshire unsurprisingly when the opera
house and harbour bridge came into view
it was an emotional moment I could see
the bridge in front of me I thought this
is what I plan for 42 years for this is
the actual final flight of it all and I
just couldn't stop smiling really you
know then flying over the actual bridge
looking at all the people doing the
bridge walk waving at me that was just
something else was that Oh Charlie hard
position it is an incredible achievement
but even more so for Dave he's paralyzed
from the waist down after breaking his
back in a motorbike accident with his
wheelchair strapped to his aircraft
nothing was going to stop this York
Sherman making the trip of a lifetime
not even a horrendous lightning storm
over Burma there was a big flash enough
the aircraft shuddered with them a
lightning strike at the side of me and
blue all the fuses out on the
instruments it got to a point where I
wasn't scared anymore and it was just
trying to survive you know not crash
crossing oceans deserts and jungle Dave
flew over 18 countries and who needs
inflight movies when you have a front
row seat of the best views mother nature
can provide raising money for yorkshire
Zaire ambulance Dave coped with sand
storms and even the threat of being shot
down over Iran now though he's just
ready to head home and in case you're
wondering Dave won't be going home by
propeller power but rather in a normal
airplane as for the microlight well
that's going to be packed up put in a
container and we'll head back to Britain
by see Dave flew all the way to
Australia on just a wing and a chair
something worth considering next time
you complain about being on a long-haul
flight
Jonathan Samuels Sky News Sydney